oui bonjour excusez moi de vous dire je
suis nicolas l'enseignante votre enfant
oui bonjour vous allez bien mais colas
poisson en cinq ans quatrième année dans
la dernière semaine il a téléphoné à ses
23 élèves parlé à leurs parents
il voulait s'assurer que tout allait
bien ça c'est bien d'enfants il faut en
plus de français de mathématiques
rentrer ça en deux parties de fortes
night ou des trucs comme ça
oui bonjour l'ambiance à venir au bout
oui est ce que tu me reconnais ok je
vais paraître mais oublié il remarque
plusieurs élèves sont anxieux que
certains parents sont inquiets pour
leurs enfants plus inquiet aussi par
apparaissent mon enfant voir doubler
toutes ces questions là je voudrais dans
notre milieu la majorité des parents
nous disait justement qu'ils font déjà
des choses à la maison pour aider les
parents le ministère de l'éducation et
les directions d'écoles vont envoyer
chaque semaine des activités
pédagogiques pour toutes les matières
pour chaque niveau du primaire et du
secondaire vie qui bossait à deux
enfants qui fréquentent le réseau public
est super motivé je pense que pour les
parents ça vaut 1
ça nous enlève un poids si on veut parce
que c'est quand même très bien structuré
les enseignants des enfants de vie qui
avait déjà commencé à mettre des
activités pédagogiques en ligne commence
et où j'ai donné quelques informations à
distance comme demain à une heure de
l'après midi on va avoir
on voit là on veut la peep ib ans il va
avoir une petite dit et si je trouve ça
vraiment né mais cool qui ont constaté
qu'il ya peu nous donner des devoirs
faire de distance comme ça peut toujours
continuer à prendre ici dans une autre
maison dans un autre quartier
manuel qui est en 2e année suit
quotidiennement les cours de madame
marie-eve une enseignante de son école
mais ce ne sont pas tous les enseignants
qui en font tant des parents sont déçus
que certains professeurs n'en fasse pas
davantage pour les aider pour leur
donner un coup de pouce
je sais que certains parents c'est comme
si on leur met ça dans la cour c'est
facile de juger faire les difficiles
mais c'est chacun fait du mieux qu'il
peut dans la situation de la semaine
prochaine les élèves québécois auront
accès à des capsules éducative sur les
ondes de télé québec et sur le web
d'autres outils pour faciliter la vie
des parents et maintenir les
apprentissages des jeunes
le ministre robert je n'écarte pas la
possibilité que l'école reprenne d'ici
la fin du mois de juin
et si j'en fus lait provient à radio
canada montréal